you know sometimes when people make
perfectly Common Sense observations like
we don't need hardcore incest porn in
schools the rejoinder will be well
you're censoring art you don't you
Philistines are trying to get rid of
culture and and sometimes even people
will say you know there's a lot of bad
stuff in the Bible you know there's
incest in the Bible there's rape in the
but do you are you now advocating that
we ban the Bible and it brings me back
to really the center of the American
debate over obscenity which which
completely spun out of control in the
middle of the 20th century it comes back
to a Supreme Court Justice named Potter
Stewart who was asked how to define
pornography and obscenity and he said
you know I can't quite Define it but I
know it when I see it and and this line
is made fun of I mean it's it's it's a
term of of derision that is thrown at
conservatives but I don't really see why
it is made fun of when as far as I can
tell
you actually do know it when you see it
is that such a crazy observation you do
I mean there's this legal definition you
know of what obscenity is I don't know
why we need a legal definition because
you do know it when you see it
um but that's what they're you know
unfortunately in Texas there is a um
obscenity exemption clause in the law
and so if it's used in an educational
for an educational purpose then it's
allowed and that's what they're hiding
behind and and um you know the the
school that in the first amendment
they're saying it violates A Child's
First Amendment rights to pull these
books off of the Shelf which I mean I
spoke to that in my first video it's
like really I mean are we violating
their second amendment rights when we
tell them they can't carry a gun to
school no because they're children we're
talking about children they don't have
the same rights that we do as adults for
good reason so are we violating their
third amendment rights when we quarter
British soldiers in there well done
never mind that's not a good one but
there are plenty of other examples no of
course we I mean first of all since when
does the first amendment protect your
right to be able to access any book you
want at a specific Library period even
if you're an adult but but then second
of all to suggest that children have
this right do children have the right to
say whatever they want in schools I
don't think so I think if I said naughty
things in schools the teacher would yell
at me and probably give me a bad grade
right and and you know I we get called
book burners a lot and ban you know
we're trying to ban books and my
argument for that is look
are we Banning cigarettes and alcohol
because we don't allow children to buy
cigarettes and alcohol are we Banning
movies because we don't allow them to
watch rated R rated X NC 17 movies are
rebanning all movies because of that are
we banning guns because we don't let
them you know carry a gun or buy a gun
no we're just limiting their access
children's access to these things
because they're not mentally emotionally
ready for this kind of either physical
or mental harm I mean you don't you they
have their brains have are so
right for I mean they're just so
impressionable is the word I'm looking
for at that age and so we have to
protect them where that's what we're
supposed to do as adults when did that
when did that stop we've always we've
always protected our kids and now all of
a sudden it's like oh no they're they're
they can handle it they need to see it
they need to know that they're not alone
um you know people they throw out the
whole
Bible thing and I actually saw somebody
online arguing that point and I'm like
okay name a Sunday school class where
the parts in the Bible about incest and
all of that are you know a Sunday school
class where they teach those passages
those passages you are hard even for an
adult sometimes to process and
understand so of course we're not going
to teach that to children in the
introduction to the Book of Genesis say
maybe you wait a year or two before
maybe yeah yeah you know you stick with
the Noah's Ark you know and Adam and Eve
you know in the garden with the apple
and all of that you know you don't hit
those those topics that are really very
difficult even sometimes for adults to
understand so gotta protect the kids and
wait until their development they're
they're developmentally ready for that
type of
material I love it when people call me a
book burner and a book banner I always
say oh you're accusing me of banning and
burning books like um Plato or like um
the apostles in the book of Acts or or
like I don't know most Great Men
throughout history who have who have you
know beyond this kind of provocative
image of of burning books who have had
standards every society has standards
and we usually apply those standards in
a in a much stricter way when we're
talking about children and they they
pretend that we're sort of somehow
monsters or like we're fascists or
something because we want to have what
every society forever has always had
which is some kind of standard you know
I mean the the real irony of this of
course is that you know up until the
middle of the 20th century every school
just about taught the Bible and banned
pornography and now now so many schools
teach pornography and the one book you
are not allowed to teach in school it's
the only one you can teach mind conf you
can teach hardcore porn the one book you
can't teach is the Bible so who's really
doing the Banning here and what sort of
banning are they doing right it's a very
good point and the whole you know
standards thing yeah they're they're
definitely trying to it feels like
they're trying to lower the standards
every day lower and lower the bar gets
lower and lower and you can't I mean the
only thing I can I can assume is that
they're they're just wanting to
normalize this stuff so that kids their
their inhibitions are honestly I I
personally feel like they're trying to
lower the inhibitions of of children so
that when they are approached you know
by I
traffickers any any kind of um
attempts to uh I don't know I mean the
pedophilia seems to be they seem to be
going towards even normalizing that
there's there are books in our libraries
that or have been I don't know if they
still are I don't quote me on that but
there have been that that depict
pedophilia you know lgbtq get gay sex
and and I don't I don't care no sex
sorry no sex neither book that I read
from had anything to do with the lgbtq
community and that's another
um that's another criticism that we get
is that we're just after you know this
certain uh segment of the population and
it's just not true when you say we don't
uh we don't want books about pederasty
in our schools they say how dare you
that's homophobic
no no you're the one who are a lot of
these two things but but of course uh
you know Shannon I can I can see you you
almost don't even want to say it you
don't even want to suggest that maybe
these guys are trying to normalize
pedophilia but of course we know that
that they are doing that I mean there
was a professor who was caught in a big
Scandal because she was caught on camera
trying to normalize pedophilia to change
even the word pedophile to map a minor
attracted person to take away the stigma
of the this orientation with which
people are born and you you see this
going on throughout the culture you're
seeing the normalization of drag queen
Story Hour what's that about it's about
bringing little kids into sexual
situations you're seeing on that same
line of thought uh drag kids these poor
little kids who are being sexually
abused and who put on little skimpy
dances and in in multiple cases have had
grown men put dollar bills in their
clothing I mean so this is not something
that you're imagining in some crazy
fever dream this is happening it's being
broadcast on the mainstream media and
and they tell us on the one hand this is
not happening it's a delusion of the far
right and on the other hand they're
saying this is happening it's so
wonderful and you better celebrate it
yeah the celebration part is where I
have an issue you know a lot of people
tell us especially as if you're a
Christian if you're a Believer we're to
love everybody and we are called to love
everybody
um but my definition of love is not
encouraging and celebrating something
that I think is destructive and and able